Is back in stock,
but it runs out all the time.
This is the easy peasy dress from Halara.
I'm 5 9 and 165 pounds.
Here's why it's called Easy Peasy.
Because it has shorts with the built in pockets.
Deep pockets. You can fit your keys,
your phone, your wallet,
anything, both sides,
and you're not stuck.
You don't have to take the whole thing off like a romper.
It's gotta break right here in the fabric
so that you can pull the shorts down
so that you can go to the bathroom.
I'm wearing my bathing suit.
Easy peasy without being uncomfortable.
This is amazing for moms chasing your kids through the park.
You can play with them,
do everything and still feel cute and fun.
There are huge discounts for first time users of the TikTok Shop.
It's linked right here if you wanna try it.
There's free shipping and free returns,
so it's completely worth it to give it a shot.